don't bring anyone love into this
surprise were you and that's truthful
wait because I was fat I was 265 yeah
when that started I was 265 how do you
think you got there for real
Oh think about it yeah I do number one I
fell off a waterfall that was the number
one that was the number one well we're
like let's say go back a couple years
what was your walk around weight I was
at 40 years old I was to 15 to 16 and
that was and I looked really good more
years ago that's four years ago yeah
Travel Channel it's slowly grant bill to
add it on add it on
I think I was floating around at 235 it
probably when I was doing trip flip up
to 35 maybe maybe to 40 yeah I hurt I
hurt my I blew out my plantar fasciitis
playing tag football and I was getting
back in shape and and I couldn't walk I
couldn't run and that's what it started
put it on and then when I fell off the
waterfall and that's what I'm learning
because I was I was addicted to oxy and
Valium my god I was eating I was eating
for I was taking oxys four times a day
and I was taking four volumes and I was
taking them together the end with the
fucking kibosh on that good yeah but but
that's when I cuz I wasn't even getting
out of bed I was like I couldn't move I
remember being in a bed in a hotel room
in North Carolina and I couldn't get
outside it couldn't reach my oxys or my
I could say oxys whatever they were
vicodins whatever they were I don't know
if it was an oxy cotton but it was oxy
cotton or whatever brain or whatever
whatever was was pretty awesome they
were really great and I couldn't get out
of bed and I pissed in the bed cuz I
couldn't get my get to my pills
except I couldn't move my back yeah but
that I think that added on and then that
last season of birth to conquer I'm just
power8 this is what claim this is why we
brought it I need to ask him that's
Gerard Depardieu and he was we were
watching this movie and as a joke we
were talking about the movie yeah and
the right before that whole thing took
off I was like oh he looks like he has
Burt stomach and now and that day when
we did that when we talked about that
that's when we started to like talk
about it basically that that day that
was what and but I didn't it won a
notice like I really didn't catch on to
it like I'd see him but I'll be like am
i fat but I really was yeah that and I
was doing that weight-loss challenge at
the time I was challenging myself to on
- doing a vlog and you guys watched it
you're like what the fuck you're doing a
vlog for what are you 13
yeah wait this is at once it started
though once we started challenging no I
think it was right before that I think
you saw that - remember what he started
doing vlogs and I was pregnant with
Ellis yeah and we won't wall had dinner
and he's like look at this boy I
remember you been like fuckin seriously
now but wait what were you eating on
Bert the conquerer like what was your
jam okay so no number one we used to do
a thing called crew crew skies so we'd
had big crews and then what that would
be was that I got to order for everybody
and then and in doing that what I would
do is I would order everything I wanted
to eat and then we've cut it up and you
could sample things yes oh yeah I've
been with you we did that in Montreal
it's the fucking best
but you always order a lot when you do
you always order a couple plates extra
so I was ordering and then it started
turning out when I'd go out to eat with
people I'd order two meals because I
didn't want cuz I so used to cruise skis
I'm having options then I didn't want
one to suck and you know then they go
all that was my meal so I'd order two
meals and then I'd I make it rain
appetizers and I think that and I
switched over oh I was drinking a lot of
beer at the time and so I think he's
just not adding up I was just no no I'm
thinking about it in my own think like I
always been a pretty big boy but it
really got off the rails when she got
pregnant yeah it really was we would go
out to breakfast like every day and we'd
always be like gotta have dessert so I
would who are you you're the one that I
that I don't think people have it in
their memory of how big you were yeah
how big were you at your biggest well
what triggered like when I remember you
know you have like a weight you're
comfortable with so I remember being
like
thinking that like 2:45 for whatever
reason was fine yeah and then at 2:55 I
remember just being like yeah but that's
like 2:45 the truth yeah yeah so like if
somebody said like how much do you weigh
when I 255 have you say 245 yeah
and in my mind be like that's not really
a lie yeah I'm like within your mind
you're 245 and then I can actually
remember getting on scales and seeing
like 258 and 261 yeah and like I
remember when it was when one sits
across 260 I was like you BB not close
to 45 but the worse with that so the one
where I was like really cuz I'd you know
I'd I'd fucked with I mean I had
trainers I had I had a trainer during
her pregnancy will you still go to boot
camp together well I'm saying yes we'd
used to go to boot camp which absolutely
was death but this trainer I mean he was
really having me fucking do tire flips
and like you know then wind sprints then
run over and do power cleans like I
would do these workouts that were like
absolutely killing me but then I would
eat absolutely everything do you
remember the time that we went and we
did CrossFit I was like I think I burn
like 10,000 K and then we went out with
Chris ty Walker yes yeah it was when two
gay bars and we had so much fun yeah and
we're killing gay drinks like all those
sugary things and then at the end of the
night we're like I've we did good today
we went to CrossFit or with CrossFit and
all we had were some vodka drinks and
then Christopher who wants pizza we're
like you're a trainer you're supposed to
be keeping it away from me and we
thought like if he's pizza yeah he's
green lighting it yeah he's saying go
ahead and do it but that's the problem
with exercise is that you don't get how
much you should be eating cuz you burn
all these calories yeah whatever you
figure out that if you do that kind of
exercise and then eat right then that
outwards
[Music]
Oh